hey guys it's max and angelica and today
what are we doing
we are doing another unbiased blind
camera comparison
and angelica's replacing vadim in this
one she's going to give us a more
real world view instead of vadim and i
being super critical about each image
which is fantastic and you have a piece
of paper ready
on there you have three phones you guys
already know which ones they are we have
the brand new note 20 ultra
of course we have the iphone 11 pro max
and i thought it would be great to put
in a brand new
budget phone 350 bucks for the pixel 4a
compared to
i think 1300 yeah that's a massive
difference in price
just to see maybe we'll get confused a
couple times here
and actually think the pixel images are
better it's going to be very
interesting now get your own piece of
paper and pen
pull out your app on your phone we want
you to do this
as well do this unbiased test and we
want to hear your guys's opinions
before we get started go ahead and check
out our new
maxtec zip up hoodie yep or we have
brand new
white face masks we know the black ones
are super popular so if you need to stay
safe you need to pick up a few of these
check out the merch shelf down below now
here we
have our first image which one looks
best to you
i think i like the one on the left the
most because you can see the most detail
in the trees with the other two it gets
kind of dark
and the detail gets crushed and that one
is the note
20 ultra so we got one point right away
for the note 20 ultra
now i'm actually taking some score as
well i've seen these images
but i'm just gonna vote for my favorite
it's not unbiased but i'll give you guys
my opinion as well i like the iphone one
because i like the pop of color i like a
little bit extra contrast
now we have a selfie i think i like the
one in the
center the most the one on the left is
extremely blown out
in the clouds and then the last one it
looks so
dark and lower color as well so another
one
for the note 20 ultra so we have a macro
shot here
i think i definitely like the one in the
center the most it seems the most
vibrant and detailed iphone 11
pro max it's very interesting how you
get so much more texture
i don't know if it's defusion here or
not and we have this tough
hdr scenario i'm not going to give you
any advice
this has to be unbiased i was about to
say something
do not uh i think i like the one
on the yeah the very left the most the
one on the very right
is doc just go i'm just joking go go you
already said the left
you can't change your mind i was gonna
say um when you look
like in the back in the shadows and the
darkest areas the one on the right it's
super crushed
it is and then the one in the middle is
still a little bit too like you can see
the most detail in there
11 pro you voted for the iphone i think
this one just looks so sharp
you know look at all the detail look how
everything pops
but they're all close they're all good
even the pixel no actually the pixel
doesn't
all right next one this is a zoom shot
wow
can you tell the difference yeah
definitely the one in the center
has the best detail and dynamic range
yes
uh it it definitely looks much better
now out of the two on the side it's just
out of curiosity which one do you think
is second place
probably the one on the right they're on
the right second right yeah
bam so of course the note 20 ultra has
that super zoom
camera that's sideways in here it's a
massive amount of difference it looks
really good
so one on the left looks really like
what is it a lot of
artifacts artifacts a lot of compression
artifacts that the pixel doesn't have
so of course the note got that one but
pixel good job
now we have a food shot here this was
some pizza that said low carb and i
figured out later
low carb okay i i have a feeling you're
going to disagree
with this i actually forgot which one is
which on this one but i know which one
i'm voting for
i like the one on the right the most you
do yeah okay yes i disagree
i like the one on the left why pixel
four
there you go and i chose the notes one
and we have a standard shot here uh i
think i like the one in the center
the most it looks really nice even
though the colors
might be off you got another one for the
note
20 and i agreed with you on that one too
the iphone's really blotchy and too
green this is a portrait shot i wanted
to do a tough scenario we got to test
the algorithms out
okay so i really i really do like the
detail of the
uh the left and the right one but since
it's a portrait shot and you look at the
background
uh the one on the left it doesn't seem
like it's working in quite a bit of like
areas and then obviously the one with
the right two so
hey the one on the right blurred half of
the tree over here
this one in the middle definitely did
the best and it's the note 20.
it did a phenomenal job yeah you look
even if there's a few miss ups but even
through here it blended
had a nice transition here on the sides
over here
everything the algorithm i think samsung
has updated it
quite a bit and here we have another
zoom image definitely the one on the
right
and that is of course the note 20 ultra
it's crazy and good lighting this looks
like like a dslr shot
it looks so good the detail is
incredible everywhere it looks fantastic
and this is a shot that i wanted to push
the hdr i'm in the shade here it's sunny
out there
i think i'm definitely going to go with
the one on the left the one in the
middle some
areas are blown out and then comparing
the left one to the right one and the
one on the left has
like brighter nicer colors and that one
is the
iphone and i would have to disagree i'd
have to go for a note again and i
actually forgot on this one too
um that just looks too cool it's sunny
outside
it's supposed to be warmer on the
concrete and this one is our first
ultra wide it looks a little bit
confusing this goes
to this image that one goes to this
image so the
pixel is not in this one we don't have
an ultrawide camera on here
i think definitely the one on the left
looks way better has way more detail way
more
the colors the one on the right is just
so dark you can't even
see very much and i wasn't trying to get
you to be biased
i personally wanted to test out detail
because they're both 12 megapixel
sensors
and the note gets another point here
and here we have our first video so i'm
gonna play this back
and let me know whatever differences you
see between them
instantly i like the one in the middle
the most i don't like the one on the
left at all it's really warm and weird
and then between the middle and the
right the one in the middle has like way
nicer
colors yeah and this is 4k 30 uh on all
of these which they can all do
the pixel i don't think you could do 4k
60. you're right the iphone looks nice
it's detail looks natural looks
really good the note 20 has an 8k sensor
and has to over sample that
and i don't know maybe we'll show a
video clip right here we have all this
artifacting on the building over there
just from
all that megapixels that has to deal
with
then i have one more video here this is
the front facing
i definitely like the one on the left
the most for sure
i hate the one in the middle it looks so
weird you do not
look human it looks so waxy uncanny
valley
stuff going on i don't like it i don't
like it all right and
that one once again the iphone the pixel
look at that the detail is smeared it is
gone my beard you can't see it
i hate it it it it doesn't look good but
let's be nice it's 350
it's cool 350. okay and this one
it's a tough white balance situation i
try to set it up that way
okay i think the one on the left
definitely looks the best the one in the
middle
the yeah the white balance is really off
it's pretty cool and then looking at the
left and the right
the one on the left looks way nicer more
detailed your car looks so nice and
shiny
i don't know if i agree but that is the
pixel four
that is actually your first one for the
pixels
i like this one it's actually a little
bit warmer
than here you see the sunset so it
actually did the white balance spot on i
had the greenery here to confuse it
i'm glad you like the pixel though i'm
glad you gave him one point
and here we have this beautiful sunset
i'm kind of stuck between the left in
the middle
but there's a lot of things i don't like
about the middle one the sky some parts
of it are blown out and there's detail
loss
and then with the with the grass and the
landscape whatever back there it just
looks really
like forced detail yeah it's over
sharp and doesn't look that natural
basically most people would agree
that's a better one and that's the
iphone 11
pro max and here is our first portrait
shot of a person of my wife
i really really like the left image it
looks so nice
but at the bottom left the portrait mode
did not work
so i think for that reason i'm gonna
have to go with the middle one
and you chose the iphone now i have to
point out
my opinion after you said yours point
something else okay
the note 20 ultra i like the skin tones
i like how much
how little noise is in there good detail
and the iphone and the pixels have quite
a bit of kind of blotchiness and noise
in the face
i'll forgive that little i actually
never even noticed that until you
pointed that out
so i'm glad samsung fixed that actually
and here is a shot of
my kids after dark the background and
this one is really blurry but it's
really i'm trying not to say anything
but it's really like artifact-y and
weird
it's just not very pleasant to look at
so the one on the right is really dark
and really cool tone
but i don't like the other two very much
at all
you chose the pixel one more for the
pixel and yeah it's very interesting to
see
we were not using the portrait mode on
here because the note20 has a much
larger sensor that's
natural blur there it doesn't look the
best compared to dslr
but the other two are completely in
focus so right it's focused on them the
background's blurred out
and here we have a selfie i know which
one you're gonna
choose definitely the left one um
no i think i think i honestly like the
one on the right the most even though
it's really
really warm like red and it's obvious
that it's like
blurring out your skin but yeah i think
i like it more
the pixel is the one you show hey is
this a streak for a pixel
or you're getting multiples now it's
starting to you know catch up there
the iphone come on apple why do we have
such a
decent looking image i still think you
know 20 is better i like the more detail
there even though
there's a little more noise but 350
right 350 bucks and it could do
um the night mode on the front face you
can see you can actually yes
this you're gonna throw that away you're
not gonna keep that no the pixel photo
it's usable looks way better
we have another night shot here this
actually seven times a zoom
in low light and there's a pretty big
difference here yeah definitely the one
on the right
and that is the note 20 ultra the iphone
looks terrible
again the pixel the white balance is not
true to life
but it looks good it looks nice and we
have our last shot here
it's a night mode shot and we have some
drastic differences
hands down definitely the one on the
right the one in the middle looks like
complete
garbage it looks awful i don't know what
happened the one because all these have
night modes
the one on the left looks also pretty
gross to be honest like it looks like
baby food like pea soup like
everything's just mushy
all the colors there's no separation in
colors really and
another one for the pixel man if only we
had more night mode shots
the darker it gets the better the better
yeah exactly
so i don't know what went wrong with the
iphone but
we're done here we got 20 different
images
what are your results and before you
mention it guys let us know down below
if you actually voted what your results
were and if you didn't vote at least
were there a couple images that surprise
you we want to hear your guys's opinions
now angelica for your blind unbiased
comparison
what did you get for the pixel 4a i got
four
points for the iphone 7 and for the note
20 ultra
nine nine so good job samsung now
for me it wasn't unbiased because i knew
some of these ahead of time i just voted
which one i thought was the best and i'd
want to have
i have three for the pixel and actually
some of them were different than the
ones you voted for the pixel
this last one i think is pretty obvious
though that's the one we matched up on
uh the iphone i got six so uh what how
much did you get six
seven seven for that and then note i got
11.
so good job samsung definitely
improvements from the s20 and some of
the downsides have been fixed
you know what actually i want to mention
i also didn't have any autofocusing
issues
which was an issue with the s20 same
camera sensor but they added the laser
see this little thing right here
yep the laser auto focusing and that
helped at all i had no issues with auto
focusing
there you guys go let us know your
thoughts and if you guys want to see
my one week real world video on the note
20 i've been switched over from my
iphone make sure you guys are subscribed
with those notifications enabled and
check out our merch check out our new
zip up hoodie
the masks the other great shirts has
been max and angelica and we will see
you
in the next video
[Music]